?
I HAVE THREE SISTERS, I HAVE A
DAUGHTER, I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE
PAIN YOU'RE GOING THROUGH RIGHT
NOW.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
>> ME?
IT'S NOT REAL YESTERDAY.
I'M IN DENIAL.
I'M HOPING FOR JUSTICE.
I'M TRYING TO SWITCH MYSELF INTO
THAT MODE.
>> I KNEE JUST CRYING AND NOT
ABLE TO SLEEP IS NOT HELPFUL.
SHY WOULD WANT ME TO REMAIN
ACTIVE AND FOCUSED ON FINDING
THE SUSPECTS.
THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
>> SHE HAD A GREAT SMILE.
I KNOW YOUR FAMILY'S BEEN
FRUSTRATED WITH THE
INVESTIGATION SO FAR.
>> YOU DID YOUR OWN WORK, FOR
INSTANCE.
YOU FOUND VIDEO OF THE FOOD
TRUCK, FOR EXAMPLE, WHERE TWO OF
THE VICTIMS WERE SEEN THE SAME
NIGHT AS THIS KILLING?
>> YEAH, I WOULD SAY -- I THINK
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY EXTREMELY
PERSONAL FOR US.
WE TREATED IT THAT WAY.
I KNOW HOW VALUABLE THOSE ARE,
AND I CAN ONLY HOPE THE POLICE
KNOW HOW VALUABLE THAT IS, AND
THEY HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION
THERE THAT JUST ISN'T PUBLIC
RIGHT NOW.
MY SISTER GOT HOME AT 1:56.
IT WASN'T 1:45.
I KNOW IT DOESN'T SEEM
SIGNIFICANT, BUT WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING FOR DASH FOOTAGE, I DO
FEEL IT IS VALUABLE.
>> KAYLEE'S MOTHER HAS SAID THE
KILLER WAS SOMEBODY SHE KNEW
WELL AND COULD BE AT THE
FUNERAL.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYONE I
TALKED TO SAID SHE KNEW
EVERYONE.
THEY HAD PARTIES THEY WERE
COLLEGE KIDS ABOUT TO GRADUATE.
SOMEBODY COULD HAVE PARTIED IN
THE HOUSE, AND GOT THE IDEA OR
THE CONFIDENCE TO PULL THAT OFF.
I'M VERY CONSCIOUS OF THE RUMORS
THAT HAVE BEEN CIRCULATED.
BUT HAVE POLICE BEEN ABLE AS TO
TANNED UP THE POSSIBILITY OF A
STALKER?
THEY SEEMS TO BE KNOCKING THAT
DOWN.
>> OBVIOUSLY ANY OF THAT
INFORMATION WAS NEW TO US.
SHE WOULD FACETIME ME ALMOST
EVERY DAY, SHE WAS CAUTIOUS,
VIGILANT.
IF SHE NOTICED SOMETHING, SHE
WOULD HAVE SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
I KNOW YOU'RE FRUSTRATIONED HOW
MUCH IS BEING SHARED WITH THE
PUBLIC.
--
>> I'M NOT GETTING ANYTHING.
THEY'RE NOT SHARING MUCH WITH
ME.
I KNOW THERE'S A SPRAYS IN
DUTIES THERE.
>> I THINK THEY MIGHT NOT KNOW A
LOT BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE
BRIEFINGS.
IF THEY HAVEN'T HAD A BRIEFING,
THEY PROBABLY DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> ARE THEY CONTACTING YOU AT
ALL?
>> TO BE HONEST, THEY'RE NOT,
YESTERDAY I ASKED ABOUT THE
STALKER QUESTION.
THEY COULDN'T CONFIRM ANYTHING,
AND TODAY I HEAR THEY'RE
REACHING OUT TO THE COMMUNITY
SAYING THAT THERE'S A STALKER
INVOLVED.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF -- THEY'RE
JUST SO VAGUE WITH EVERYTHING
THEY SAY, SLOWLY PEELING BACK
THE LAKERS TO FIND THE REAL
STORY.
IT ALL STARTED WITH A
SHARP-EDGED WEAPON, TELLING THE
COMMUNITY THAT, INSTEAD OF JUST
COMING OUT AND SAYING IT WAS A
KNIFE, YOU KNOW?
YOU'RE NOT HOLDING THE INTEGRITY
OF THE CASE TOGETHER.
>> I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE
FRUSTRATIONS FOR HOW POLICE AND
INVESTIGATORS HAVE HANDLED THE
CRIME SCENE.
>> WELL, THEY EXPANDED IT, THERE
WERE VOLUNTEERS THAT WALKED
AROUND.
MANY DISCLOSED THEY WERE LOOKING
AT DIFFERENT THINGS.
THEY DID SHARE WITH ME THAT THEY
HAD MORE TO DO WITH KEEPING
CAMERAS OUT THAN IT DOES
EVIDENCE GATHERING.
I HOPE THAT IS INDEED THE CASE.
IT WOULD BE DISHEARTENING A WEEK
LATER TO NOT HAVE --
>> THE MOTHER OF ONE OF THE
SURVIVING ROOMMATES, THERE WERE
TWO ROOMMATES WHO SURVIVED THIS,
TOLD REPORTERS THEY HEARD
SOMETHING, HEARD SOMETHING THAT
NIGHT.
HAVE BEEN TOLD?
HAVE YOU HEARD IN SHARING WITH
OTHER RELATIVES WHAT THAT WAS,
EXACTLY?
>> I WOULD SAY FOR US, WE DID
HEAR THOSE RUMORS, BUT RIGHT NOW
NONE OF THAT HAS EVER BEEN
CONFIRMED TO US.
>> THE SURVIVING ROOMMATES, THEY
WERE DOWNSTAIRS, JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT.
>> BUT ON A DIFFERENT FLOOR FROM
WHERE IT APPEARS THESE MURDERS
TOOK PLACE.
ONE CONSISTENT THING, AND
GRANTED THERE IS BEEN SOME
CHANGES AS YOU NOTE, ONE DO YOU
KNOW IF POLICE BELIEVE ONE
PERSON IN THE HOUSE WAS THE
TARGET OF THIS ATTACK, OUR ALL
FOUR?
>> I'VE BEEN TOLD IT'S ONE, BUT
THEN AGAIN THERE'S THE
VAGUENESS.
PURPOSELY VAGUE, AND HOPING, BUT
IT CONFUSES EVERYONE.
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THAT MEANS.
OTHER THAN MAYBE SOMEBODY HAD A
DIFFERENT KIND OF ATTACK.
>> WE DON'T HAVE ANY REAL
TANGIBLE INFORMATION TO WORK
FROM.
INK I GET IT, YOU WANT TO HELP.
I'M SURE YOU DO WANT TO HELP.
HAS ANYONE INDICATED TO YOU,
THAT IF IT WAS INDEED ONE PERSON
TARGETED, WAS KAYLEE THE TARGET?
>> THEY WON'T CONFIRM ANY OF
THAT TO US.
I679.
>> WE'RE HEAVED THE RUMORS THAT
THAT'S THE CASE, BUT NOTHING
FROM THE POLICE.
>> AND A LOT OF THOSE -- ALL OF
THEM -- IT'S HUMAN NATURE TO
WANT ANSWERS, TO KIND OF PUT
FORTH A THEORY, SO YOU CAN EVEN
COMPREHEND IT, SO I THINK THAT'S
HOW WE'RE GETTING SOME OF THESE
REALLY, REALLY OFF THE WALL
THEORIES.
AND WE'RE SITTING HERE
SCRATCHING OUR HEAD SAYING, NO.
>> I AM SURE IT IS FRUSTRATING.
YOUR FAMILY HAS BEEN VERY
OUTSPOKEN IN SUPPORT OF JACK,
KAYLEE'S EX-BOYFRIEND, BUT ON
THE POLICE SITE, HE'S NOT
LISTED, NOTABLY AS SOMEONE WHO
HAS BEEN CLEARED?
>> INCLUDE ANY ASSOCIATE
>> SOME OF THE LAST FOOTAGE,
SHE'S ON HER PHONE 24/7.
SHE LIVED ON THAT PHONE.
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE THE DELAYS
HERE IN SHARING INFORMATION, THE
DELAYS IN, WELL, FRANKLY MAKING
MORE PROGRESS ON THE
INVESTIGATION MEAN THE POLICE
HAVE LOST THEIR BEST
OPPORTUNITY, RIGHT?
I THINK, OLIVIA, YOU WERE SAYING
THE EARLY HOURS AND DAYS ARE
KEY.
THAT'S WHEN YOU CAN MAKE REAL
PROGRESS.
DO YOU BELIEVE THEY MAY HAVE
MISSED THEIR BEST CHANCE HERE?
>> NOT ONLY IS THAT, BUT THAT'S
A MATTER OF FACT.
YOU LOOK STATISTICALLY AT
HOMICIDE CASES, THE FIRST TEN
DAYS ARE SO INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
IN FINDING A SUSPECT.
SO, YE